has enough pawns left to win and uh all  black needs to do is take the white  pawns and make a new pass  point for himself the queen is just  going to outmatch the rook  this should be game over any moment wow  what a performance by magnus carlsen in  a must-win situation  these types of positions sometimes you  can create a fortress if you have your  rook on a nice  square but here there's just no safe  squares for that white rook  napoli actually i think he's about to  resign 30 seconds left  there we go napoli actually resigns  it is over magnus carlsen and the first  of two must win games he does  win shaking his head feeling maybe  relieved he does have one more game now  to do it yana pognacci he wasn't able  here  to save only that draw a loss here means  we have a fourth game  between these two and if magnus wins it  it's gonna go